or forwards in time to one particular
moment you'd happily relive again and
again what would it be and why mm-hmm
where isn't my daughter pain and all I
was going to say was fine I mean how you
know what I mean like the first yeah
that's a beautiful moment yeah that
moment I would I hold it very clear of
my brain you know I don't see this me
I'd like to be pretty president life so
I want to be forward or backwards I kind
of like to be always where I'm at and
then and the memories I have of my pasts
are pretty vivid and clear so neural map
back to a good time about time but on
the flip side then the language side of
things obviously maybe your character
you very very gifted linguist I just
wondered how well though your language
skills translate in real life like can
we speak any other languages know what I
thought we could have been fun today and
I thought you might want to embrace
trying to learn a new language where do
ya well I'm well we're gonna go in hard
with both feet the longest place name in
the UK I warn you is 58 letters and this
is a real this is a real place in way of
say two first because that's gonna
really make it so much simpler so what
we're going for is clarified puddin get
go get a [ __ ]
I plan to say do go go go I'll get to go
go go it looks like written down glenda
sleep zone it just sounds like I'm
making fun of no with Clemson plan fire
push push gringas quincas go Gary go gay
Quinn draw boy I just if I just do it
with a side words list
all right Santa Sally oh wait fun at the
last wasteland si leo slam dysley go go
go that's the [ __ ] that's amazingly if
you ever go anywhere if Aryan it's
awesome the long as URL a parody on the
net on the web Thanks
I know how did this see when I look at
this I do go kind of this is what I have
in common with Louise why was it named
this what actually means something I
tell you what exactly
some memories church in the hollow of
the white hazel near the rapid whirlpool
of thunders idea of the red cave I would
rather learn how to say like you know
where's dinner all set to go thank you
it's such an is that so interesting I've
never really heard any well so well
you're welcome and thanks for the movie
and good luck with it
thank you and very well my coffee is
kicked in I can totally feel it it's I
like like that's that I'm not sensitive
to substances that it's like coffee it's
just like I know right I know